this test today it's important i got it
i'm gonna make you look good up there
don't worry okay now let's get these
pants off
and fly some planes it's no secret that
ryan reynolds first met blake lively on
set of the 2011 movie green lantern and
despite the movie being a massive flop
at the box office
their love soared off screen joining
jason bateman sean hayes and will arnett
on their smartless podcast
the vancouver-born actor shared some
insights on the early days of his now
10-year relationship with blake
now i met blake on the on the darkest
crease in the air of the universe called
green lantern
and we were friends and buddies and then
um
about a year and a half later we
actually went out on a double date but
we were dating separate people
wow really she was doubling with someone
else okay yeah she went on a date with
someone else i was on a date with
someone and and
we hung out and kind of you know we were
we always kind of kept in touch but sort
of
casually and then next thing you know
she was going to boston i was going to
boston so i was like well let's i'll
i'll
ride with you and according to ryan from
that moment on the rest
was history how long after you started
dating
your friends then you start dating how
long were you guys like this is it this
is the real deal
pretty quick honestly it was kind of one
of those
silly sort of like out of a fairy tale
it was like a week later i was like
we should buy a house together wow i
know and we did
fast forward to the present ryan is now
a proud girl dad of three and admits
that homeschooling his two eldest
daughters during the pandemic was a lot
more difficult than he originally
thought
dude they had a tough time man yes i was
like seeking out
external help left right so i was
reading books i was like trying to
figure out some way to
to s steer the ship so it was blake was
blake was so much better at it than i
was
um because i was i'm also a child the
deadpool star goes on to share
how he's been able to stay busy while
making his marriage work
year after year the only reason i think
i'm able to continue
doing this at this this way i think is
that i'm
present with my kids yeah and my wife
and my marriage is
incredibly important to me and that
friendship is important to me so i i
you know i'm able to kind of get through
you know but then blake and i don't do
movies at the same time so she's ready
to go back and do some salt i'll step
down and and then you know we'll
we go back and forth you guys alternate
yeah she'll yeah she'll do a film and
i'll just be
you know with her on on location hanging
with the kids so you take you take the
kids with you on location always
always